a transgender woman brutally attacked in
Texas last month was found shot and
killed over the weekend video from
April's assault shows several men
beating the woman in a Dallas parking
lot CBS this morning investigative
correspondent and a Warner has been
following this story for us Anna good
morning
look at that video good morning
community and political leaders are
mourning Malaysia Booker's death
Democratic presidential contenders
Kamala Harris Elizabeth Warren and Pete
Buddha judge are calling for action
while better O'Rourke tweeted that
transgender women of color across
America deserve better close to you less
than a month after speaking out about
her attack malaysia booker was found
shot to death in a dallas neighborhood
upon arrival officers found the
complainant lying face down in the
street deceased from homicidal violence
Booker's previous assault in April was
captured on cell phone video the 23
year-old told authorities she was beaten
following a minor traffic accident and
said her attacker is used homophobic
slurs authorities charged Edward Thomas
with aggravated assault although it was
flagged as a hate crime
gender identity is not listed under
Texas's hate crime statute at this point
police have not connected that attack to
Booker's murder her father hopes it
wasn't a targeted killing I pray to you
was it cuz I don't want to see nobody's
child go through any of this nobody's
family everywhere we go she was people
well she was picked on because she's
transgender advocacy groups say attacks
on transgender people in the US are on
the rise last year the Human Rights
Campaign tracked at least 26 deaths due
to fatal violence the majority of
victims were black transgender women
experts say as shocking as the numbers
are the number of victims could be even
higher so often they will remain silent
and the data we have is based on the
folks who have reported we don't know
about the folks who suffer in silence a
man accused of beating Booker last month
is out of jail but police say there's
nothing to connect him to Booker's death
the
Wright's campaign says Booker is the
fifth transgender person killed in 2019
but a important point there at the end
we there are a lot of these cases just
don't get reported and abuse in these
instances yeah I guess they're talking
about people being frightened into
silence yeah and I remember when we
first saw the video of Malaysia Booker
and that beating is very interesting
they don't they don't know if there's a
connection between that case and the guy
who is now out right that's what they're
saying that's the police are saying they
really don't know there's any connect
very upsetting story thank you Anna